[Music]
so my name is Sammy I'm 27 and I'm in
enterprise sales so I work with CIOs and
about nine states and try to move them
to the cloud
I'm Tony I'm 28 and I'm in strategic
sales in a software company where we
work on marketing and brand strategy
through their links
okay you ready for my questions why did
you agree to do this I know that is a
good question the reason I really agreed
to do this is because we never talk
about minority women versus other women
because there's a huge wage gap between
men and women but there's a wage gap
between white women and women of color
and that's a conversation that doesn't
get brought up a lot I don't necessarily
want to be the one to be open and to
share my salary and everything but I
think it's very important that you know
some women of color and are included in
this conversation it's awesome yeah why
did you agree I would self-identify as a
feminist I like how could I get an
opportunity to do this and say now do
you feel like you're paid what you
deserve
oh that is so direct I definitely
wouldn't complain about the amount of
money I make I think it's great but I do
know that a lot of my peers make more
money than me and I don't think that
it's completely based on merit so I
guess the answer is no what about you I
think generally speaking I'm pretty okay
in the short term if I continue to get
paid when I close the deals what I
expect to get paid it's okay did you
negotiate your pay I did um I actually
worked with a negotiation coach that
works very closely with women she
definitely helped me a lot negotiation
is a skill women aren't as comfortable
bragging about themselves putting
themselves on a pedestal or even being
aggressive in general and it's kind of
something you need to do if you want to
get what you want and so they gave you a
number and you said no that's correct
are you ready I'm ready okay three two
one let's go boom boom
curveball what should we say no
curveball on us so do you know what the
pay gap is between white men and black
women no not at all no idea can you
guess I don't even know it's about sixty
six cents to the dollar sixty six is a
huge difference what do you think
explains why this case defies the pay
gap my assumption is that if you don't
know your value relative mm-hmm it's
hard to demand it yeah and that's why
like I wanted to be here to shine a
light I remember when I was younger my
mom took a huge pay cut to leave a job
that she hated and I think it affected
me in a way I really do care both about
how I feel in the role but also making
sure that the way I'm compensated makes
me feel the way I want to feel also but
I'm not sure that's the case for
everyone what do you think I think
they're like you know a lot of factors
that are at play in terms of women of
color specifically and men why their
salaries are so different I think there
might be disparities in terms of
education and they're like financial
issues maybe they can't afford to go to
a very expensive private school for
example I think there are lots of other
reasons especially in the corporate
world for example I'm the only black
female a high team in North America
right and that's pretty normal for me
like throughout my career to be the only
one or maybe one of two maximum for
example I get different reactions
depending on what I do with my hair hmm
so if I you know put my hair in braids
or if I wear my hair in an afro you know
that kind of changes the reaction I get
when I go in for an interview and so in
my experience I have to come in and
really like change the whole perception
of black woman to start and then I can
kind of start taking you more steps
forward does that make sense
solutely yeah my biggest takeaway is
there are so many things I don't have to
think about yeah it's crazy what about
this experience surprised you the most
so I am aware enough to know that I have
been afforded a lot of opportunities
what I think has shown up the most for
me so far is just how like much of a
mental burden I don't have to carry yeah
that's surprising because I fancy myself
like thoughtful and modern enough to be
aware that's like really crazy how much
I miss Wow what surprised me the most is
like the exact opposite of what you just
had I think you are I guess
quote-unquote woked is the word like
maybe you don't know everything but you
do you know know enough and you
understand and you're open-minded enough
to kind of listen and get it and I think
that's like super positive and that's
why more these conversations should
happen it was great yeah that's my
pleasure cool love it
[Music]